it's crazy too because you came from
like you know obviously in Detroit
there's this there was this other era of
like horrorcore rap kind of right right
you think of like uh esham King Gordy uh
obviously the psychopath record [ __ ]
um that was this other like this whole
other thing going on out there at the
same time and you kind of also or were
like privy to as well you personally
obviously yeah yeah that movement like
like obviously I want to get to the ICP
beef but okay uh I'm curious like uh was
was there like a
that scene of Detroit hip-hop that was
like more like really underground like
I don't know if it's horrorcore but you
know what I mean the ICP the esham the
King Gordy [ __ ] you know yeah they had
like a they had his own land of his own
you know what I'm saying and uh and it
was very specific to that area and I'm
gonna be honest with you
I already never knew nothing about that
world until I started [ __ ] with King
Gordy
because Ken Gordy was signed the fbt
which was the same production company
well Marshall was signed too so that's
how we met King Gordy and then I started
[ __ ] with him and when we started
doing our projects
he he was already kind of in in the in
the jugular world so he kind of
you know and introduced me to it so it
was nothing like I never that I sought
after I kind of I grew up with hip-hop
boom map of course and it was like it's
kind of it's kind of a weird world you
know to be honest why why yeah
definitely yeah yeah
they're all grown up now yeah I've
yet to meet like a 17 year old Juggalo
like now like these days you know like
they're all like
right 37 why minimum yeah right it's
still out here rocking oh it's crazy
though because like you know I'll say
this about them they really
uh revolutionized merch yeah they
revolutionized being independent
definitely they did some things that a
lot of people are practicing nowadays I
think that they helped
show like guys like Tech Nine away and
Strange Music the way yeah you know so
but when you guys had your back and
forth by the way some of the best skits
ever
Ken can connect from Connecticut [ __ ]
all that [ __ ] and I definitely was not a
big ICP fan growing up I thought that
[ __ ] was terrible but I've gone to their
shows like I've had Faygo fly by me they
used to launch Faygo in the [ __ ]
crowd yeah they gather
um but uh uh how crazy did that ever get
was that anything other than just being
comedic or being like just some rap [ __ ]
some 90s rap beef [ __ ] or was it ever
like oh no no I got seriously yeah how
serious did it get
um it was serious like your sight if we
see them they see us it's whatever and I
think they ran into Marshall at a
car shop or some [ __ ] like way back in
the day
I forgot what happened but yeah it was
it was it was it was serious man I
remember one time uh
we had a show at St Andrew
and uh I guess ICP had like a talent
show or something in the basement and
what we was performing up top and we
didn't know each other was going to be
there
and uh I just remember they fans their
fans gave it away because they were they
were dressed like seeing them no not
even they was just giving us the meanest
like the dirtiest [ __ ] looks and I'm
like what the [ __ ] everybody why you
[ __ ] keep looking at me
everybody was like ICP in the basement
I'm like oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] but I
think they end up squashing that beef
that day okay and trick tricking uh
Violet J yeah damn that's crazy that
sounds like a hairy situation yeah you
guys are upstairs there downstairs in
the middle of a beat yeah yeah that
could have gone first time we ever seen
each other over a year was your
situation with esham did it have
anything to do with with ICP thing
because I know he was over there for a
little it was just something separate
nope uh I know but I think ishan you
know I think ishan his thing was
Marshall was showing him the respect
by saying he was a cross between each
arm and Nazi and um I don't know I bet
she I guess he took that disrespect or
whatever and
which is a crazy thing it takes yeah
yeah in retrospect ishan right now is
probably playing that line for his uh
for his kids and being like look Eminem
said
also kind of like you know kind of set a
lot of that groundwork for what uh yeah
he definitely elected Detroit Legend
yeah it shows you to be he was in high
school doing that [ __ ] selling out shows
wow that's [ __ ] crazy man